[Applause]
you're back in action Peter Webber but
this time around you're the one handing
out roses season 24 The Bachelor is
going to be one bumpy ride but you're
used to the turbulence by now you may
have gone from contestant to bachelor
but all those rules are still fresh in
your mind you know exactly how the
contestants feel and you're familiar
with all the strict rules they have to
follow after all it wasn't that long ago
that you had to follow them yourself
we've lined up ten of the most
surprising rules every bachelor
contestant has to follow so don't go
anywhere you won't believe which rule
puts its contestants in imminent danger
how far will ABC go to keep their
viewers entertained keep watching to
find out hold on to your bling you would
think that the contestants on The
Bachelor would rack in some serious
dough especially after making it to the
final 12 but that just isn't the case
contestants aren't paid for appearing on
the show but if there's one thing that
keeps them going it's the knee lane
diamond rings the finalists are gifted
at the end of the season but we should
warn you gifted isn't exactly the best
word to use
after all producers of the show can ask
for the ring back if contestants fail to
follow their rules
these Neil Lane diamond rings have been
valued from anywhere between 50,000 and
100,000 dollars but finalists shouldn't
get too attached their bling because it
could be taken away from them just like
that Jessie since act the Bachelorette
winner who got engaged to Dianna pop us
at the end of season four let Hollywood
calm in on a little secret
according to Jessie contestants sign a
contract before appearing on the show
and this contract forbids the couple
from keeping their rings if they break
up within two years of the season
finales airdate BYO w while contestants
don't have to bring their own wine they
certainly have to bring their own
wardrobes while this might not seem like
a big deal buying a brand-new wardrobe
is super expensive and as previously
mentioned the vast majority of the
bachelor contestants are never paid for
appearing on the reality dating show so
applying to the show is a huge gamble
many of these women have to quit their
jobs buy new wardrobes and continue
paying their mortgages while starring on
the ABC series
knowing this contestants are all the
more driven to win the bachelors
but to do this they have to stand out
which makes buying an impressive
wardrobe that much more important
former contestant Jillian Harris had to
remortgage her house before appearing on
the show and she's spent a whopping
eight thousand dollars on new clothes
but that amount pales in comparison to
how much a season 20 contestants spent
on her new wardrobe
Olivia Caridi is rumored to have spent
around forty thousand dollars on clothes
all while respecting the - suitcase /
contestant rule cut all contact with the
outside world now this rule may seem
like a given but that doesn't make it
any easier to follow most people aren't
glued to their phones and are accustomed
to using the internet at leisure but
when you become a contestant on The
Bachelor you have to kiss technology
goodbye contestants have to disconnect
from the outside world they can't call
their mom's to vent about their feelings
or talk about the Mean Girls on the show
and they can't catch up with their best
friends they're completely alienated
from the outside world watching TV or
staying up to date with current events
just isn't allowed and not knowing
what's going on around you can make
keeping your head in the game all the
more challenging but ABC executives just
can't risk letting their contestants
spoil their season's events before it
hits the small screen but at least the
contestants have a beautiful mansion to
explore right well not exactly
did you know that the mansion doesn't
have any AC that's right
air conditioning makes too much noise
and interfere with the mics that makes
sharing a house with 20-something other
girls harder than it needs to be respect
the mic contestants constantly need to
have their mics on this way everything
gets recorded as a result AC is out of
the question but that's not the only
thing that mics clash with earlier on we
mentioned that ABC puts their
contestants lives in danger by
entertaining a certain rule and that
rule goes as follows
contestants can't eat while out on dates
this is due to the Mike's picking up on
chewing and let's face it no one likes a
loud chewer
but since the show's producers encourage
contestants to drink this can have
detrimental effects on their health
eating too little and drinking too much
can make contestants feel sick and tired
and top that off with a lack of air
conditioning and things are bound to get
ugly
knowing this producers let the girls eat
between the two date portions this way
they can remain level-headed but
many of these dates have contestants
wearing daring outfits many of them keep
their meals to a minimum to prevent
themselves from looking bloated on
camera no sleeping around
according to insider a season of The
Bachelor takes a total of nine weeks to
film and a lot can happen in just nine
short weeks ABC executives encouraged
their contestants to get in the
screaming matches as well as shed a few
tears but if there's one thing they
don't want contestants to do its sleep
around contestants aren't allowed to
sleep with The Bachelor before they get
to the fantasy suite and that's a rule
that everyone has to follow but
respecting this rule isn't always easy
especially when contestants are bored
isolated and encouraged to drink by
producers believe it or not but some
contestants end up mingling with the
crew and since sleeping around is
forbidden contestants have been kicked
off the reality dating show without a
moment's notice season 14 contestant
Roslyn Papa found this out the hard way
Roslyn was booted off the show for
allegedly hooking up with crew member
Ryan Callahan who also lost his job
admits the scandal here at the things we
love finding out about the ins and outs
of your favorite TV shows if you do to
hit that subscribe button and turn on
notifications so you never miss another
video switch up your YouTube settings if
you're watching on your phone or tablet
now let's get back to the exciting
second half of our video say yes to the
date one of the best parts of The
Bachelor is watching contestants go on
ridiculous dates with their alleged
future fiance problem is some of these
dates are so pretty it's hard to watch
before appearing on the show contestants
agree to say yes to the date no matter
how absurd it turns out to be so if
producers tell them to go skiing down
the hills of San Francisco and their
bikinis they better be ready wow this
date idea might sound absurd it's
exactly what happened in season 16
episode 3 of The Bachelor but as it
turns out skiing down a hill in a bikini
isn't all that bad after all the girls
can be asked to partake in extreme
sports like skydiving waterskiing cliff
diving and everything in between
most people don't mind if their partners
have a fear of heights but if
contestants aren't willing to jump out
of a plane for the future fiance they'll
get booted off the show without a
moment's notice don't talk about the
finale the bachelor and the night
99 film Fight Club have a lot in common
this is made obvious by the club's
number-one rule don't talk about Fight
Club this also happens to be the number
one rule for the bachelor that is if you
replace Fight Club with the finale
anyone who talks about the finale before
it airs on TV will pay the ultimate
price and that price is 5 million
dollars a lot of effort goes into
keeping the season's finalists a secret
when filming wraps up the final couple
has to hide out in a safe house to keep
each other a secret while the show is
airing but the finale isn't the only
thing contestants can't talk about in
fact there's a certain word that is
strictly banned from the program and
that's the P word we're talking about
the word process of course according to
contestants the word process is
off-limits because it takes away from
the show's romantic angle and talking
about politics is also off-limits since
political talk can anger viewers
contestants are forbidden from talking
about their political views on camera
kiss your privacy goodbye contestants
are forbidden from using technology
during their 9 week stay at the mansion
but this rule only applies to them
throughout the show's production period
contestants agree to being filmed all
day every day so in other words they can
kiss their privacy goodbye the second
they walk through the mansion doors the
only time the girls aren't being filmed
is when they're using the bathroom
the contestants are also made to wear
mics from the moment they wake up in the
morning to the second they go to sleep
at night but cameras are always on them
even when they sleep every single moment
of The Bachelor is filmed and recorded
except for when contestants win an
evening stay in the fantasy suite with
The Bachelor but while the show only
takes nine weeks to film contestants
belong to ABC for a total of 12 months
this rule prevents them from being cast
in any other productions during this
time the exam period ABC producers only
want the best matches for their
bachelors which is why they test
contestants before casting them on the
show
first and foremost producers want to
make sure that their contestants aren't
optimal health both physically and
mentally since many of the dates require
contestants to be in tip-top shape it's
crucial if they pass the physical with
flying colors the physical also prevents
producers from picking contestants with
health issues as this could stop them
from completing the season on a side
note contestants are also screened for
STDs meant
valuations are also vital as contestants
will be pushed to their limits during
their stay at the mansion once the
contestants receive the green light from
ABC's personnel they're also asked to
perform a camera test because being
camera shy just isn't an option
while these tests may seem intrusive
they help protect everyone who agrees to
appear on the show stay together for the
fans but simply making it to the finish
line isn't enough to keep a couple
together and in the past couples have
broken up before the final episode aired
on TV but since viewers want the happily
ever after they were promised breaking
up just isn't an option according to
Lewis Fenton the show's producer
contestants agreed to stay together for
the fans until the finale and reunion
episode to make headlines this keeps the
magic alive for viewers while securing
the show's credibility so the season's
final couple chooses to call it quits
they have to go on pretending like
they're in love dating other people
during this time counts as a contract
breach and could land the finalists in
hot waters with ABC but since a
million-dollar lawsuit would ensue most
contestants don't have an issue when it
comes to respecting this rule respecting
all these rules can seem impossible when
you're on the outside looking in but
contestants don't really have a choice
in the matter
who do you think is gonna win Peter
Webber's heart in season 24 of The
Bachelor sound off in the comments
before you go give this video a big
thumbs up we'll see you next time on the
things thanks for watching
[Music]